in the English-speaking world the
Orthodox view now is that we have been
terrible people the terrible history
have done terrible damage to the world
and we should be very ashamed of
ourselves and the Russians and the
Chinese love this
Putin has referred to it in some of his
speeches the Russian foreign Ministry
put out as a long piece the other week
about Britain's Colonial sins and saying
how it was good that this was now being
looked at it's used politically against
us and I would say against the interests
of of democracy and it does undermine in
in Britain certainly in Canada in
Australia in America any sense that
these countries have any positive
achievements and this is constantly
saying that no that's not true you're
all racists you always were racists in
the past your racist now we're racist in
the future it's all about white
privilege it's all about colonialism and
so on and this has to be destroyed and
as one of my colleagues said if you
deconstruct the West what is going to
replace it